When I was a young person at school they taught
us that we had five senses, but I would argue
today that they have overlooked a very important
sixth sense, which is the sense of balance.
The sense of balance is absolutely essential
to upright walking animals like human beings,
and we achieve balance using some senses that
are located in our inner ear, in the vestibular
apparatus where we have the equivalent of
accelerometers and gyroscopes that provide
the information to keep us upright. Balance is absolutely critical and the human being’s sixth sense.
Other animals have evolved different sensing
modalities to those the humans have. For instance,
small flying animals like bats have the sense
of echo location; they send out pulses of
acoustic energy and listen for the reflections
and they use this when they are flying at
quite high speed at night to find obstacles
that they would want to avoid and to find
insects that they would wish to eat.
Sharks create an electric field around their
body and then they can sense disturbances
in their electric field, which are caused
by fish swimming in close proximity to the
shark’s body, and this is really useful
for them in order to detect sources of food.
Finally, pigeons have got an innate sense
of magnetism. They have magnetic senses in
their heads that allow them to tell where
north is and this is absolutely essential
for them in their flying long distances, an
essential navigational aid.
Now for us, it’s almost impossible to imagine
what a sense of ‘northness’ feels like,
but pigeons have that sense, so there are
many, many, different senses that animals
have evolved over time to help them perform
the essential functions of life.